[Musique]
jean-paul chang bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france allant on le
disait un lâcher une première puissance
économique économique mondial en 2022
1028 selon une projection
parmi les raisons le fait que le pays à
rebondir rapidement après les premiers
effets de la pandémie de kobe de 19
s'accroissant s'élèvera à 2 % en 2020
pourquoi l'économie chinoise a résisté à
la pandémie
écoutez le dans un premier temps elle a
souffert d'apprendre mais comme tout le
monde puisque vous savez qu'au premier
trimestre 2009 les données chinoises a
chuté de 6 8 9% ce qui était beaucoup sa
première fois historiquement et mais
comme la maîtrise de la pandémie a été
très rapide dès fin mars début avril les
activités ont reprises le confinement
d'une province du coupé même si c'est
une crevasse industrielle importante n'a
pas trop impacter le reste de chine où
il ya d'autres bassins industriels tant
qu'activité avait repris dans l'ensemble
plutôt qu'ailleurs donc rapidité de la
maîtrise du virus fait que bon reprise
plus rapide donc au dès le deuxième
trimestre la croissance a contre avec 2%
positif et au troisième trimestre mais à
4 8 9% ce qui fait que sur l'ensemble de
l'année en effet la chine va sortir avec
un rythme de croissance de pib de 2%
probablement aussi il ya eu également
les exportations chinoises qui se sont
envolés depuis le 21 pour cent en
novembre avec notamment la vente de
matériel médical la vente de masques
est-ce que c'est uniquement ce secteur
qui a permis à la chine de prolonger sa
croissance économique
moi pas du tout pas du tout il ya eu
quand même deux mesures des mesures
budgétaires importantes
oui aussi des mesures monétaires donc
buzz autour de réserve des banques des
banques nationales de faciliter des
crédits etc
bon il ya une sorte de relance d'abord
l'exportation des reproductions en
reprise c'est peut-être un phénomène
saisonnier lié en gros aux deux
de mondial infos les fêtes de fin
d'année et donc il ya eu effectivement
un bond des exportations au mois de
novembre
cela étant tout ça est quand même très
conjoncturel ce qui à grand chose à voir
à mon avis avec la projection du think
tank britannique qui se projette qu'ils
prennent
disons que ce redémarrage rapide ce
petit décalage aujourd'hui entre les
cônes et chinoises et le reste du monde
coffret accompli alors là je pense qu'il
faut comprendre c'est plus vite on
maîtrise la pandémie et que l'économie
va reprendre lorsque les pays les autres
pays sont parvenus à à maîtriser les
leurs l'épidémie je pense que le reste
de l'économie va augmenter aussi
ceci dit les chinois ont pris cette
projection britannique avec beaucoup
beaucoup de méfiance j'ai vu la presse
chinoise qui a quand même pas mal réagi
ils disent quand même qu'il ya
probablement d'autres intentions
derrière c'est cette analyse
quelle intention par exemple ces deux
finalement de réveiller finalement les
pays occidentaux de dire attention des
chinois sont à 32 de démarrer donc il
faut se mobiliser
or on est dans un contexte où la chine
est déjà présenté un peu comme une
bonnasse presque systématique depuis
quelques mois par donc le fait de
présenter la chine comme une grande
rivale tu à nous dépasser et de
finalement
considéré par les chiens comme comme un
message relativement dangereux d'autant
plus qu'ils sont persuadés que la
comparaison simple de pib entre entre
entre des pays ne signifie pas grand
chose que par exemple sur le plan de la
comparaison de deux puissances
respectives des états unis de la chine
bien entendu ce n'est pas seulement sur
le chiffre du pib que ça va jouer que
même en europe que même si un jour le
pib chinois a dépassé celui des etats
unis
la puissance américaine combinée de
synthétiser avec l'ensemble des autres
aspects finalement de la puissance
militaire monétaires etc
la chine sa rencontre est très loin donc
quelque part ils ne sont ils sont bien
sûr elissa que cette année qui sont
contents d'être d'être la seule grande
puissance avoir une belle croissance
positive mais il se laisse pas abuser
simplement par une sorte de de fierté
qui serait fondée sur des espérances
tout est un peu folle voilà il y avait
le mandat de donald trump qui a été
notamment marquée par la guerre
commerciale entre la chine et les états
unis on constate aujourd'hui les
sanctions de l'administration trump ne
semble pas avoir eu d'effet sur
l'économie chinoise en tout cas quand on
lit les conclusions de cette projection
pourquoi selon vous les effets vont
arriver parce qu'en fait comme elle
oblige les mesures sont extrêmement dur
en ce qui concerne les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
la chine est très dépendante encore dans
un certain nombre de domaines
technologiques des états unis par
exemple dans tout ce qui est plus
électronique tout ce qui est l'industrie
donc de haute technologie or les mesures
contre dur là est fait pour vous ce
qu'on voit c'est on a déjà vu quand même
un ralentissement mais c'est surtout le
ralentissement américain lui même qui a
masqué finalement le décalage entre les
chinois et éventuellement l'économie
américaine mais il est clair que les
chinois sont conscients du fait que dans
les cinq ans qui viennent au même les 6
10 ans qui viennent
les difficultés qui vont rencontrer du
côté des états unis
on est de plus en plus
importante et en fait c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans la 14e point canal
qui sera approuvé au printemps les
chinois mise énormément sur la
possibilité de parvenir à l'autonomie
sur un certain nombre de 70 clés et
qu'il ferait que ne peut qu' il ne
serait pas étrangler éventuellement par
par des sanctions américaines mais sans
aucune illusion sur la continuation des
sanctions d'ordre technologique
tentative de découplement même avec une
administration ped
oui parce que justement en quelques mots
pour conclure c'est catherine taille qui
va prendre les rênes de la politique
commerciale américaine sous
l'administration maiden donc selon vous
la stratégie américaine ne va pas
changer vis-à-vis de la chine
je pense qu'il y aura une forme de
dialogue de renouveler peut-être y aura
pas d' échanges de noms d'oiseaux comme
ça a été le cas ces dernières ces
dernières semaines mais le dialogue sans
à une très dure et que sur le sociologue
sur le fond les geeks américaine que ce
soit réputé quelle qu'elle soit
républicaine ou démocrate va continuer à
mettre la pression sur la chine pour
empêcher finalement la chine de
rattraper ou de dépasser les états unis
trop vite
merci beaucoup jean-paul chang d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin dans
la matinale d'arreter frange rappelle
que vous êtes économiste et spécialiste
de la chine